untold story I got one real quick I
never received a national championship
ring from the University of Florida uh
but that's another conversation for a
different day
some of the things that I did not like
about the documentary was how they
played Chris leak in my opinion I was
watching it like they said things like
we're we were just one quarterback away
like bro Chrisley was that
like let's not forget how pretty of a
ball he threw and it started as a
freshman in the SEC
uh from Independence High School out of
Charlotte like what are we talking about
like granted Tebow is everything and
some but bruh let's not try to dim the
lights of of Chrisley lastly where were
these players I really wanted to hear
from Percy Harvin Joe Hayden uh the
pouncy twins like there was so much that
they left out but other than that it was
a good document